it's almost time to go but before we do
we like to leave you with a little
something to take on the go in the doggy
bag
and today it's an incredible non-profit
that we featured in the current magazine
that i make yes it has my name on it
just a kind note is recruiting letter
writers to be part of their movement to
spread kindness one note at a time and
you can sign up with a commitment to
write at least three notes a month and
they'll hook you up with addresses for
some people who could really use some
kindness elderly people college kids
first responders small business owners
and it's designed to require no response
from those who get the letters just
kindness with no strings attached and
they've already sent out eighteen
thousand notes rossi wow okay i'm in i'm
in i know i wanna i wanna do this too
let's do it all right okay hopefully
maybe someone will want to join in on
this wonderful cause and thank you to
all our guests for being here at the
studio today
[Applause]
to spend your time with us take this
good energy
with you that's what you take on the go
we'll see you soon
[Music]
you